depuis des siècles aucun humain n'a eu
le pouvoir de se transformer en monstre
jusqu'à aujourd'hui c'est pas dangereux
ce bidule
[Musique]
est-ce que tout va bien par ici
qu'est-ce qui est sympa
[Musique]
avec la brioche
ta gueule like bon qu'est-ce qui se
passe
[Musique]
comme tu veux
et on peut savoir qui sont ces gens
c'est moi qui me reconnais pas comment
te reconnaître c'est la première fois
que je te vois
vous devrez vous rendre aux femmes de la
magie où se cache le seul moyen
d'inverser la mutation
je ne suis qu'un humain
si on ne vous soigne pas rapidement vous
allez rester comme ça
dès que c'était marrant le 14 janvier
seulement sur prime vidéo